And I'm gonna shoot you the
All right. I'm gonna send you the
whiteboard.
Perfect.
How's it going everyone? Um, we're back
to episode number 12 13. Uh, and today
our whole goal is we're going to talk
about how to get the tone just right
when we're prompting. I think a lot of
times when we're building a prompt, we
talked about this last time when we
built the AI content pipeline.
It's really first it's essential to get
the information correct and presented
the way you want to get it presented,
but then you want to go do part two. And
part two is actually making the prompts
do what you want them to do. And I think
last time we spent a lot of time talking
about the infrastructure, the tooling,
and also just getting the data across
and some by coding processes that Dexter
and I use when we go do this.
I think today our goal is we want to
talk a little bit more about exactly how
we're going to go ahead and make these
prompts better. So just to recap
everyone, Dexter, do you want to show
everyone what like we were do what we
were doing yesterday with yesterday's
pipeline or last week's sorry? Yeah. So
like I have the whiteboard here. I just
made a copy of the one from last week
because we're going to add to it. Um but
we built this system with a back end and
a front end and a data bot base and kind
of an API in between them. um and these
kind of pipelines where we would take a
Zoom meeting idea, we download the video
and send it to YouTube and summarize the
transcript and then draft a bunch of
content uh based on that video. Um and
we had a little bit of like a human loop
refinement workflow. Um
let me see
if I I think I have it running. Um
actually I'm you can just run the new
one. It's fine too. Yeah, there you go.
Yeah. So this is this is the updated
version of it. Um, so you can see we've
kind of done some imports. Um, we've
added a bunch of stuff, um, like
connecting the Luma events to the Zoom
meetings using some mix of AI and not
AI. Um, we've added, uh, what is it?
This be the ability to create a draft PR
and GitHub, which I'll show you what one
of those looks like. Um,
but then it's, you know, we've got the
summarization of the key points. We have
this timestamp stump that we looked at
and then it will generate a Twitter
thread and a LinkedIn post and an email
for and some of you from last time
probably got this email and you probably
noticed that we had a little bug in
there where it said hello first name. It
turns out when you do generate content
go ahead. Did we send the email with
hello first name? we did because the
email templating system that we have
doesn't actually it needs a variable
plugged in in a very specific way for
the actual first name and you know parts
of doing AI generated content is that
mistakes like this happen I mean that
would happen even if you're a human so
it's not just restricted to humans are
just AI pipelines but this is like a bug
that we have to be aware of because to
take it to like that last degree we're
always going to run into these kinds of
edge cases where like maybe the AI gener
and we'll inject first name later in the
pipeline as well. So, we have to think
about that and think about how we can
make that error better along the way.
Yeah. Um and then yeah, the other the
other cool feature was basically um and
we can get into this code as well, I
think. Um but if we go to I can show you
um
this auto here's an autogenerated pull
request for last week's episode. Um, and
so it's using a different title and a
couple other click on the top right
instead of code instead of the markdown
view through the full proper view on the
bottom. Oh, not there. Sorry. Uh, I'll
draw on your screen right here. Oh. Oh,
I see. Yeah.
Um, so it's done a pretty good job. If
you've seen the other readmes in this
repo, it's looks a lot like the other
episodes that we've done. Oh, that's a
workshop. Uh, if we look at one of these
and you come look at the read Oh, okay.
Oh, this one. Yeah, that was your
episode. You were supposed to upload the
read me for that one. I know, I know, I
know.
Um, but so here's like our normal readme
format where we'll have some whiteboards
and then we'll have some code and then
we'll talk about how to run it. So, it's
it's it's able to and we'll look at how
this context gets built, but basically
looking at previous readmemes, it's able
to draft a um what this what this should
look like and leave we've prompted to
like leave certain sections blank
because we'll just the goal is always to
like reduce the amount of human effort.
Um I don't think we'll ever eliminate it
and if we if we if we if we hold off on
deploying a system until everything is
perfect, then we'll never get anything
out. Um, and I think this adds a lot of
value with a couple while still, you
know, leaving a couple things. It goes
to a couple Can you go up really fast
that? Yeah, it goes to like a couple
things. For example, the whiteboards,
then we'd have to build a Excal
integration that can go pull data from
there. And that just takes time and
getting an LLM to exactly take the
perfect screenshots. Like, that's a
problem that's easier for Dexter and I
to do than to write the code for doing
this. The goal of projects when you
build AI pipelines is not to automate
everything.
The goal of a project is to get a good
value of time for uh good value for the
time that you put in. So Dexter and I
take roughly five to eight hours to
automate this to do this work every
week.
If we're going to go do that, spending
10 hours to automate it isn't that bad,
assuming that we keep doing more
content, which I think we will for a
while. Yeah. Um, but the whiteboard
stuff is, you know, I can literally just
come here and grab one of these and copy
it and then paste it into GitHub and
that takes me 30 seconds. And to write
the code, it's like the easiest part of
the whole workflow. So, we're like,
cool, we're not going to write code for
that. We're going to let the LM do
things the LM is really good at and
we're going to write, we're going to
just manually do the things that we can
do.
And it's not that we can't do the AI
part. It's just not worth the time. And
I think that's what we go into because
if the whiteboards are bad, then we have
to go in and go edit it. And that is
where it breaks down. Kyle, then your
point about what to do is different. I
will also say that I think we do quite a
bit of uh customizing the whiteboards.
So like this whiteboard is actually four
different screenshots that are like
ordered and annotated in a specific way
because the the full whiteboard would be
unintelligible.
Exactly. So it's not that we couldn't do
it. We could definitely build a pipeline
that automates this. It's just not worth
the time. It's faster for Dexter and I
to spend five minutes doing that work
than uh not doing it
with that. I think I want to talk about
I want to talk a little bit more about
the architecture here and the kinds of
data that we were able to plum through.
Dexture drew an amazing whiteboard that
actually talks about how to collect some
of this data for this pipeline. Talks
about some more of the problems that we
have because before we can get the tone
right again uh let's show and let's show
the email that we have really fasture
just so people have it. I think you
should have it as well. Not this one the
other one that we actually sent out. the
one that actually got sent. Uh I think I
have that one.
Uh let's see. And let's talk about some
of the details that we need in order to
get the tone right because again before
we can actually do the prompting, we all
have to understand what are we aiming
for and what is the golden data set that
would really really be good.
If you look hello first name, you'll
find it. Yeah, there we go. There you
go.
Uh
so scroll down. So, there's a couple uh
sorry, a little bit up. I realize that I
can't control your screen. There's a
couple of things that we need. One, if
you go up, uh
we need the title to be correct.
Uh this is very, very important. We need
some sort of nice line here that feels
like a flow that is kind of different
every single time probably because it'd
be boring to read the same thing or we'd
rather not have that line.
Um, we probably don't need anything
special here, but we do need the links
to be correct for the YouTube video and
for the GitHub repo. Ideally, we would
put the right link to the folder there.
The only reason we don't do that is
because it takes work to find that
folder, and that's annoying, but the
email would be a better email if it took
you right to that folder. So, we'd like
to go do that. Oh, way to find a folder.
I can show you that. We'll talk about I
know we'll talk about that. I saw your
code.
We want to have a little summary here
that is not too long um and really
varies based on the task that we're
doing.
And then do you want to scroll down?
Yeah.
And then after that, what we want is
we'll really want like this one key
takeaway because like we said, it's just
useful to have one good summary rather
than five bullet points written over
here. And then we'll want to And then
the last part go down. Yep.
Clear my screen. There we go. Sorry. Um
and the last part we'll want is really
about like action items for what someone
can do next. That means the Luma link
has to be right. The title has to be
right. And then we probably want to tell
people the right date of when they can
go go join this nest event. So there's a
lot of components to this that if we
don't get it perfectly right, it's going
to be annoying. The part where tone is
the most important is really this middle
section about the content and the
summary. We don't want it to be too
long. We don't want it to be too
redundant. We don't want to use like AI
hype words. We wanted to really just
nail like the content part of it which
is hard uh because if you if you
trivially prompt a model, at least from
what I have tried, most of the time it
doesn't really do that correctly.
So getting that tone of like content to
uh uh content to quality is going to be
a little bit tricky to get. But really a
lot of it is about plumbing in the right
data into the right places, the right
YouTube link, the right folder names,
the right next uh workshops, the right
oneline takeaway, the right titles. A
lot of things are really just about
assembling the right data. So in order
to do that, go ahead. Yeah. So so so I
think this is where you're going. Um,
are you are you kind of driving towards
My instinct as we talk about this is
almost like creating a plain text
template and then filling it in with
smaller bits of LM generated content or
do you still want the because we talk
about also like these longer strings
with lots of like random characters in
them are a little bit hard for AI to
reproduce super reliably. I mean I think
a short URL like this I've never seen a
Frontier model ever screw that up.
I think we toss in a big model like two
Gemini 25 GT40
uh like Sonnet um or Sonnet or something
like that, it'll probably not mess up a
short URL like that that doesn't have
too many weird characters. It should
almost definitely work for them. Yeah.
But I think the more important thing is
actually that I want to share with
everyone is the thing that we did before
we did all of this work, which is we
drew that diagram and that diagram is
essential to actually understanding it.
So, let's pull that up really fast. So,
this is the behind the scenes of how
Dexter and I actually built this
pipeline, how we talked about it because
it not it's not just enough for us to be
able to build it. We really need to be
able to talk about this in a really nice
way that helps us understand what's
happening. Well, and it's like the
dependencies, right? It's like, okay, if
I want to write the email, what are the
pieces I need? Okay, I need the summary
and I need the next event and I need the
YouTube URL and I need the thumbnail
URL. I don't need the thumbnail, but I
need the YouTube URL to go into the
summary. So it's like what are all the
pieces and how do we get them? And this
was how we sort of like even like broke
up the work and and worked kind of
asynchronously on this stuff. Exactly.
So like it all starts with the Zoom
meeting and that's what we had before.
Then what we did part two is we added
the Luma integration and that was a
little bit trickier than most people
would expect which was what we wanted to
do was using Luma just directly pull out
data and connect it to the Zoom meeting.
And that
that's that's what looks that's what
this is over here, right? Is so we we
fetch the list of Zoom recordings and
then we try to match them to a specific
Luma event. Uh this happens to be
connected to Vibb's uh company Zoom. So
there's a bunch of random meet Yeah,
there's a there's a bunch of random uh
meetings in here that aren't connected
to Luma events. Um, and so being able to
match those to the event lets us get the
title in properly and lets us get the
summary of the event in properly that
helps us prompt everything else more
more correctly. This is all just like
engineering the right context.
Yes. Do you want to share a little bit
about um the Luma side of the pipeline
really fast? How we're able to go do
that? Yeah. Let's go pull the problem
the problems in there are I think are
not very obvious.
Yeah. So this function is actually quite
long. Um we have two things. We have
fetch the upcoming event which is
basically like let's look at a list of
events from Luma and decide which one is
coming soon is the next event because
when we generate the email we want to be
able to figure that out. And you could
do a bunch of logic of like okay let's
look at the start time and then like
let's filter them to only ones in the
future. This is deterministic code. I
mean AI can do this, but this is
basically just math. And so your code
should do this for you. And then we'll
sort them by the start time and then
that's when we go to the AI side. So we
give a very basic description. This is
um we have this luma event object which
is lots and lots of fields that we're
going to use in lots of other places.
But actually for the thing we pass the
LM we're doing a custom serializer. So
we're just sending a subset. We're only
sending the next 10 events. Um, and then
we're going to ask, yeah, I want to
pause there really fast. This is what
Dexter often says as context
engineering.
The trivial thing to do is pass in the
Luma event object. We could all do that.
The right thing to do so we don't have
to think about it is context engineering
where we decide and know that here's the
context that is relevant for the LM.
Let's give it that context. And now
we're And now we don't have to think
about it anymore. Yeah. And it all ends
up going into the prompt. So you could
call this prompt engineering, but since
it's like basically you're ragging,
you're you're retrieving data in a
custom way and feeding it to the LM in
the way that's going to work best for
the LM.
Yeah. So we took out we took out as much
data as possible and then just put stuff
in. So like if you Oh, go ahead. And if
you if you haven't seen this picture
before, um, context engineering is
basically
embracing that everything that you pass
to an LM, whether it's the prompt or the
agentic history or something called
memory or rag or how you tell to, it's
all just tokens to the LM. And so you
need to think of all of these things
together and like even the order in
which you pass these things in is a
practice of engineering of trying
different things and finding what works.
And the only reason that structured
outputs lives on the boundary here is
because you do have to tell the LM how
to do structured outputs in some way.
Whether you use JSON mode, whether you
use any SAP, any other XML, it doesn't
really matter. That's you telling the LM
how you want to do it. And at some
point, you'll write some code that
converts the response of the LM to the
structured output. And that's why it
lives across the boundary of both things
because you need regular code and I'll
send a way to describe it to the LM as a
part of its context on what you're
trying to go do.
But everything that we're going to do
with an LM is always complex
engineering.
Cool. Yep.
Uh, cool. Back to the code. You ready to
look at the prompt? Let's show the
prompt.
Cool. So, here's our prompt. Um, let's
see. So, we got to see which event is
the next AI that works event. Um, so
we're going to lur loop over there those
events. We're actually going to format
them even more. Um, and so I think I
have a test for this. Now,
um,
oh god, just make a test.
Was it summarize ammo?
Yeah,
I'll probably make a test pretty pretty.
I think it'll it might make a good test.
Uh but while we go read the prop,
there's something some nice that we do
which is like and the reason that Dex
did this is because our Luma doesn't
only have a couple of uh events. It has
multiple events. Sometimes we do inerson
ones, sometimes we use virtual ones. And
rather than thinking about writing the
code to only filter for things because
sometimes we forget the emoji, sometimes
we name it uh differently, sometimes we
don't call it AI that works. There's so
many reasons why the event might not
match.
We just let it know that these are the
general constraints. And now we just let
the LM go pick this. And this is kind of
what I think the superpower of LM is,
which is you don't actually have to get
it perfectly right. You can get it
mostly right. And now you can go ship
something really fast. It's like you
don't have to make your code perfectly
fast. You can just use Python and that's
acceptable. Um
you can put current date or something.
Yeah.
um
601 and start date is 0701.
Let's put it on 625.
We'll actually do a realistic one.
And this problem's pretty easy. So,
yeah. And this problem's pretty easy, so
it should just work. And can you put a
past state event really fast just to
make sure that it does work correctly in
case we had no events that were correct?
Um,
bye Bob.
Birthday Zoom. I don't know what your
birthday is, but
he's turning what are you, like 22.
Yep, exactly. And maybe 16 again.
Um, cool.
Uh, should be probably different. Yeah.
Yeah, that's interesting. I bet this is
specifically a bad test because yeah,
the LM will see that those IDs are just
like stubs.
Um anyway, yeah, that's fine. Yeah,
cool. Um sorry, you were talking about
this prompt here. Yeah, I want to talk
about one thing in the prompt. Uh if you
scroll up, Dexter, look at what model
you use. Yeah. Uh we use a really small
model because this is Yeah, it's a super
easy task, so we don't have to think
about it. So, we just go do this. Um,
and then we do our, this is a best
effort thing. If we don't find an event,
we don't find an event. It's probably a
user bug, so we can go fix it. It's not
really, we don't, this isn't super
critical to us. We can just go change
the Luma event description and make it
match manually as well. Yep.
Yeah. Yep. Where did we pass this in?
Sorry, I'm trying to find the
trying to go find where we called this
thing. You can just command click
from here.
Oh, not from there. Oh, you have to
search this command F. Yeah, here we go.
Yeah, sorry. So, if we don't get a
result, we say, "Hey, we couldn't find
the next event." Um, otherwise, we go
pull that event out and we return it.
Yep, that's it. So, it's a pretty
straightforward thing. We just rely on
the ID matching to do the trick. Um, so
we return our original Duma event that
is enriched, but the LM only produces
the one that is not as enriched.
So, it gives us a better Go ahead. Yeah,
I was going to say and like I don't
think we should spend time on this
today, but this would feels like a
perfect example of like where you're
always talking about like don't use the
actual native IDs because they can be
long, but like replace this with like
K1, K2, K3 kind of, right? Exly it or
just like event ID one. In this context,
I would call it like event underscore 1
2 3 4 5 6. It's just going to be easier
for the model. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's
one less thing the model has to think
about. Yeah.
Um, cool. Anyways, that's that code.
Let's pop. And then one last piece of
code I want to show, which is the folder
code. The folder matching code. This is
also kind of Oh, yeah. Yep. Actually do
all of this stuff to go produce the
GitHub reviews to go send the right
email to the right folder. Like the
email can't really be sent until we have
the GitHub uh PR ready as well because
we need we want to link you to the right
folder ideally. So, how are we going to
go do that?
Yeah, exactly. Kyle nailed it. It's like
it it just it's just it's the token
probability thing. Tokens that are
random are just not in the data set of
the model. So, it's just going to at
some point start it's going to be like
I'm printing out a UU ID. Let me just
print out UU IDs and those are basically
random. And you're you're praying that
the LM is really really really good at
needle hack tests. Yep.
Um, so what we're going to do is we're
going to fetch the existing folders and
some file contents. We're going to get
the next folder name and a couple other
things. We're going to use the next
folder name to create the readme for the
new branch. Um, so this readme we had in
our pull request. This file the our
application needs to know this full
exact path. So it needs to know the
folder name and that folder may already
exist on the main branch or it might not
and we need to generate it. And so we
need like this is a thing you could
probably write a bunch of code for to
determinate like build deterministically
every time. It would be really hard to
build the actual slug like the the name
for the folder. Um so what we did was we
took the existing list of folders and
I'll show you the code and then we took
the title of the episode and the date
and we said hey AI model like either
pick the existing folder if it's already
there or generate the name of the new
folder if it's not there. And all of
these get added. We do this manually
every every week. They get added to this
like repo like route the list of
episodes.
Um can you go down really fast and also
mention the other part the table?
Uh oh yeah and then we also update Yeah,
we also update the table. Yeah, good
call. Let me show So let me show what
that looks like. And there's there's
basically every episode every week we
push the YouTube link and the code link
for the past episode and then we post
the description about the next episode
and we have the Luma link and so that's
why in order to do the GitHub updates we
need not only the uh past stuff but we
also need the next event and its link.
So we need the title and the link to the
next event so that we can populate
this uh where is this um
this table as well. And the whole and
the whole point of going really deep
into these concepts is talking about how
much work it takes to get tone just
right. Like in order to get the tone
perfectly right on the email, the first
thing we really have to get is like we
have to break down the problem to make
sure that the data is correct. If the
factual data is wrong, the tone doesn't
matter because I'll just read it and it
won't work. But we have to actually get
all of that correct and if we don't have
the right information. Yeah. Well, oh
like I just reating what you said like
the to generate to like solve this
problem we need to know what the
boundaries what the walls of the box
are. I think I want to say where it's
like okay we're going to have to this is
going to be a hard-coded thing that
we're going to have to have to force in.
I don't want to make the AI generate
that. This is going to be a hard-coded
thing. And so that kind of starts to
structure. Okay, what are we going to
ask the AI to do and what do we want to
be deterministic? Because once we have
that structure and those pieces, then we
can start to tone engineer, content
engineer each of the different parts of
that LM's workflow and break down the
problem. Exactly. And then we're
basically just trying to break down
exactly what said. We just try to break
down the problem as much as possible to
get it perfect. And that's because we
care about the tone of the email going
out. And we really just want it to be
automated, but we also don't we'd rather
do the work manually than send out
something automated that's shitty. So
given that work, we have to put in a lot
more effort to make it happy. It's
unlikely that you can get to the perfect
tone with just prompting. You will have
mistakes like hello first name. You will
have um mistakes like wrong YouTube
URLs. You'll have mistakes like wrong
luma links. And those are basically
catastrophic in these scenarios. like it
just loses a lot of trust. So, we want
to make sure those all things get
squared away.
Um, answer. Yeah, sorry. Quickly answer
one of the questions from the chat,
which was where are the where are the
diagrams? Um, I did move this file to
readme.md.backup
just so we could test the PR stuff. But,
um, let's let me just put it back so you
can see it. This will have all of the
whiteboards in it. Um, so you can see
all the whiteboards from last week in
the previous episode notes. the new one
that you're talking about, uh, Pashant,
the actual architecture, that will be
coming in in this week's episode. Yeah,
this one.
Um, cool. Uh, we haven't seen spiral
computer. Let's to go back to the folder
code deck. You want to pull that up and
then we'll start prompt engineering
after we do that and actually talk about
the email content. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Go ahead. Are you supporting
native Rust? Uh, we will. We're I think
today we're going to release Go support
and then Rust support should be easy.
But let's talk about this today. I want
to talk about the folder content. Yeah.
So um the workflow for GitHub is again
we will figure out the episode repo path
which is like that's how we generate the
folder name and then we generate the
readme for the episode and then we
generate the updates for the root readme
and then we are going to basically use a
uh a repo called supersonic from the
case folks that lets you just create
GitHub PRs in a single line. So we give
the repo name, we give it the files we
want to update. Yeah, it's dope.
Um and then the branch named
Yeah. A couple of the things that we're
doing. Can you go down? Yeah. Um uh
which is we're actually hard coding
these file names. We're not letting the
LLM make the like go up.
Uh sorry, one more. Uh right here in the
PR. Technically, we could have made this
whole thing a tool call. This could have
been a tool call where the LM decides
what PR to create. The reason we didn't
do that is because we know that the LM
should only ever modify two files, two
readmemes. So, we just won't even give
it that choice. And this goes back to
what we talked about again. It's like
whenever we build an LM pipeline, we as
a team always get a choice of how much
flexibility we give the LM. There's no
flexibility, which is we hardcode
everything. And then there's full
flexibility where the agent is literally
making every single decision and you
have no programmatic code except mapping
the data model to the tool call and
nothing else. And I I can tell you
exactly what would happen if we had the
LLM to call this tool is I would spend I
would be like you have a tool to create
PRs and then I would write like a two
sentence prompt that would be like only
create this file and this file and
here's how you should create those
files. And then it would [__] it up and
it would do something wrong and then it
would uh and then it would create and
then I would keep making the prompt
bigger and bigger and I would have all
caps, you must only ever create these
files. And it's like if you already know
exactly what it should be, like why are
you trying to turn your own words, push
it through an LLM and output the JSON or
the code for what should happen. If you
already know exactly what should happen,
let the LM do what it does well, which
is generate the read me, generate the
readme, and generate the folder, and you
own everything else. If you know what it
is, and it's going to be the same every
time, yeah, it's less flexible, and you
can't use it as a general purpose agent
that does everything, but like again,
but we don't need that here. We don't
need that. We just need to automate the
things that we know we need to automate.
Yeah. And this goes back to thinking
really hard about what is the input span
of the problem that you're solving. So
like the input span of the problem we're
solving could be everything. But in
dextrous and I case we've decided that
we only need to automate this part of
the workflow which is a very small slice
of the world which is not the whole
thing which is all we want to do is take
content from zoom and produce a PR from
it given the content that we have. So we
can throw away all the other workflows
and not spend any time thinking about
them and that helps us basically
constrain what we have to go get the LM
to do. If we did have to make the full
PR for everything including the code
then we expand it or we can
incrementally expand it over time as
well.
And and it's like automate with AI,
automate with code and automate
manually, right? Yeah. And Joseph is
asking a really interesting question
like are we generating everything
sequentially or partially or like what
does latency look like? Well, the good
part here is it's really up to us as a
developer how much we want to go ahead
and go do. Um in our case, I think we do
we do the summarization step
sequentially because it's a dependency
and then we try and do all of these in
parallel but now because we know the
GitHub fold the email will actually
depend on the folder name and the GitHub
repo. Now the email has a dependency on
the actual readme.
Now we can remove that dependency from
being as strong simply by saying that
we'll create an intermediate step which
is a new folder name and that becomes a
dependency for the email. So now the
email and the root can run in parallel
and we use really really small steps
that are actual dependencies along the
way. And this graph starts to look
really really complicated because that's
software. Software is complicated. And
the part about it that's complicated is
not the AI part. It's just like these
questions that Dex and I ask
architecturally that make it complicated
and sophisticated over time. Um like the
parallels question Joseph is asking.
That's the question that we have to ask.
We could do everything sequentially.
We'd like not to, but we could. And this
is exactly why this sort of thinking I
find to be personally very very useful.
Um with that, let's continue.
Uh let's actually talk about uh I think
you showed the folder prompt. I showed
this folder prompt. I was thinking we
could look briefly at the readme prompts
as well. Uh well so I showed the folder
function here. This is where we so this
is where we get the path. And so here is
our examples of repo names. And so what
we're going to do is use another repo
called kit from the same people who do
the PR stuff. This is kit is a toolkit
for getting from remote repos. highly
recommend for anyone building any GitHub
automation. It's very very good. Yeah.
Um yeah, from kit import repository. So
we're going to go like loop over the f
file tree and then we basically take the
folders and it's just f of path. So
we're just going to pass in a list of
folders. Um I'm actually notice again we
could have passed this whole thing to
the lm, but Dexter was like this took me
two seconds of code. So I'll limit it to
just the folder and only the root code.
I won't think about it. Yeah. Yeah. Not
saying literally Claude just Claude just
wrote this function with very little
input. I was just like here's how we're
going to do this and it was like all
right let's go. Yeah. And again and it's
just slightly better than passing
everything to the model. And then we
just ask the model to tell us what given
the current video title what is the best
folder.
Yeah. So we can say AI the what was the
video title was like AI content
pipeline. Yeah. And the thing was 06
and the existing folders were you know
0617 and 0610
something cool
something else cooler and then you can
basically run this test. And so what
this this what this returns actually is
a episode path result which is the path
and whether it already exists whether
it's new or not and we're going to use
that. Um so it says okay cool episode
path content pipeline is new true.
Great. And then we can make another one
to Yeah. Go ahead. And the reason that
we don't just use like a standard slug
one, by the way, over here
is because a standard slug approach is
actually going to be a little bit more
annoying than you'd expect because
turning our Zoom titles into slugs
doesn't actually mean that they make
good folder names. Mhm. So that's why we
used an LM here.
And actually, I'm just going to use our
real folder names here. That's probably
better. Oops. No, no, no, no. Not paste
an entire Excalibur into
Son, let's do that.
And Dexter is one of the best people I
know to actually do all the stuff. He's
like he's just leveraging AI to like do
codegen really fast, which would have
been a copy and paste job. It's just
very convenient.
And then you can get rid of AI content
pipeline, too.
Well, I want I wanted to detect one that
already exists. Oh, yes, it did. So,
here it is. So, it figured out the
episode path. So you could do some math
and be like, "Okay, does the date
match?" Then pull that one out. But um
and yeah, the giving an explanation on
great for this
an exact match title also matches the
folder topic since there's an exact
match. Yeah, exactly.
All right. Now, let's do the I think the
part that most people are here for,
which is let's make the prompts actually
good. Yeah. Do you want to drive for
this part? Yeah, I will. Um so I think
one last question. Is there any tooling
to hook in evaluation steps? in between
these steps. Um, yes, I think it's Yeah.
Okay. Yeah, that's okay. I mean, not in
our system. I mean, I So, I'll just I'll
just uh I'll just say that I've been
using the like the the boundary cloud
stuff and it's really really good. I
don't know if that's like publicly
available yet, but um you can record
every input output pair and use it to
generate tests and eval at least at like
the per prompt level. um the end to end
eval stuff. If you want to learn more,
we do a bunch of stuff on that on a
diff. We did an episode a couple weeks
ago all about evals and the different
like tiers of like really unit testy
evals and then vibe evals and like human
evals versus like more structured evals,
all that kind of stuff. Yeah. Uh that
video probably does better, but it eval
sadly just take effort and like people I
think they want the same prompts where
they just want a prompt that works and
magically makes a perfect email.
There's no prompt that will do that
magically. At least not yet. Maybe in
like another six months, but as with
today, not yet. And same thing with
emails. Um, I'm going to screen share.
Um, I will attempt to not show API keys.
Um,
sorry, this is my ghost stuff.
All
right, there we go. Okay,
um vertex
patient. Sorry, that's testing on
different models along the way.
Uh please
okay.
So last time when we were doing this,
one of the things I think we noticed was
um
the email draft was not very good um for
a couple reasons. I think and I think
part of the reason that the draft wasn't
very good was actually that the summary
was quite bad.
Oh yo, you got to do real time codes.
Remember we did it last week and the
time codes were all in just like 15inute
increments. Okay. Yeah. So, it turns out
one of the best models for doing this is
actually Gemini. Um, and this is just it
just takes hacking with a prompt to go
do this. Last time when we did this, um,
generate email structure. Uh, where's
the summary? Sorry.
Uh, generate email drafts. I was working
on this.
Last time when we did this, we weren't
using Gemini. We were using OpenAI
GPT40.
And there's a couple things wrong with
this, but like I'll run this really fast
just to show what happens.
And this just goes to show like really
we talk about this stuff all the time,
but like I guess Gemma is doing like
decent time codes this time,
but like these times start to get like a
as we go into this, but you'll notice
this is much better.
This is actually much better than we're
doing. Did you make this prank better or
something?
I may have also done that, but I don't
actually think so. Time data is still a
string. Um,
I think if I swatch it, swap it to time
data. I'll try again.
Uh, GT40.
Let's try mini.
That's kind of slow last time, so I
don't want that.
Okay. I mean, it just looks like the
model, for some reason, I'm getting sent
off to a better version of the model
today last time. But in generalizing
you, they're not quantitizing. What we
saw last time, if you go if everyone
goes back and looks is they were just
breaking down like 10 15 minute chunks.
But even here, I'm only getting like
really nine nine time segments in an
hour and a half video. Maybe that's
good, maybe that's bad. Um, but what I
found is personally,
uh, Gemini works really, really well for
this kind of stuff. Um, and I suspect
it's because they train more on YouTube
than probably other models do. Like you
just see the time code here. Like check
that out.
Uh that's just a lot better than this
one.
And you're still just sending the raw
transcript from Zoom, right? I'm I'm not
even sending the video. I'm just sending
the raw transcript. Like Gemini model
like actually breaks this down to proper
time codes if you can look. Those are
really those are almost too small. Those
are like 20 second chunks. Exactly.
So it's actually give me 20 second
chunks. Um so we can tell it that we can
say uh not do that description usually
uh usually uh 20 to 30 second semantic
chunks
uh maybe like since these are longer
videos let's make it different usually
like five to 10 yeah five 10 minutes I
think is good semantic chunks but exact
timings
transcript.
So, let's try this again. And what we'll
notice here is like the reason that
we're focusing so much energy on getting
the summary just right
is because let's see what it does.
It may not listen to me and I can't
really force it to listen to me.
And I suspect I know what's happening
here.
What's happening here is that the model
is doing its thing. And there was 104
chunks last time. Um, and I suspect it
actually got cut off because of um
context window length.
I probably just need to out uh it
probably just needs to output more
tokens or output less tokens.
Um, this one seems similar. So, let's
try and go do this again. Um,
instead of adding the time data in here,
I'll remove this and I'll simply have
the LLM,
I'll put it as a response format. And I
suspect the reason that this is
happening is actually because what the
LM is doing is that the LM is not
forgetting my instructions because
there's so much in the context window
that it's that it's just like getting
lost among the transcript itself.
Exactly. like just like like it knows
it's supposed to be summarizing
something and you can maybe give it a
little bit of format but I was running a
token visualizer on a prompt that is too
big.
Oh yeah, don't do that. Yeah.
Yeah. Um but this prompt is just like
too big. Like this this transcript is
just like
where it go
where's the test. This test is literally
just
long. It's a lot of context. And now,
and that's probably why it's trying to
output like a bajillion um tokens to me
because when the model sees this, I bet
you when it was outputting time codes,
it's literally just converting each one
of these into a time code. I bet there's
104 10. Oh, wow. Yeah, you're just
labeling every single one. Okay. I was
gonna I was just gonna zoom out for a
sec because I know we're gonna supposed
to talk about tone today and we got
about 15 minutes left on the on the on
the main session.
Go ahead. I was going to go fix the
prompt. Yeah. No, I was just going to
say the I mean the summarization stuff I
think we spent a lot of time on last
week and I'm I'm wondering if we can go
like push this towards like your some of
the stuff you're doing with the prompt
for the email and things like that. I
could go do that right away, but the
summarization stuff as it turns out I
think is going to be very
straightforward. All we have to do is we
just change it. We just change our
instructions. The main takeaway here is
like using using models like Gemini can
help you do this long context stuff a
lot better. Right. Exactly. And also
what you'll notice is I actually have
the model dumping out stuff before it
does anything.
Um so I actually change the order what I
do. I dump out the transcript first,
then I dump out my instructions.
And that can make a huge difference in
the quality of my answer.
Um,
and
then the video
ranges and then let me go take this out.
You lost your output format. Keep it to
five uh notes
max.
And then this will probably do it. It
was just doing too much of it in there.
Mhm.
There we go. Now it works. And the
reason is I basically had the model go
ahead and break down the chunks of like
here's five chunks that made semantic
sense to it. The beginning, the middle,
other middle, and then eventually it had
the end
and it then built a I built then built a
better takeaways. Now let's do the next
part which is actually generating the
email perfectly.
So when we go actually generate this
email,
there's a couple of things on here that
we want to do. One, we want to give it
uh we want to give it the email example
of like another email that we liked. The
next thing that we want to do is we want
to start giving it video summary, email
structure, and everything else. But when
we give it the email structure, it's
going to go give it all of these
concepts. And then we're also going to
go give it a couple more things, which
is we're going to give it
information about the next session
that's already in here. And then we're
going to uh where this Okay, sorry. Let
me pull up the right test case. I
apologize for this. There we go.
So, let's just copy and paste the
summary and
replace the summary with this one
because this is a slightly better
version of it.
Correct.
Okay. So, you're using the outputs from
the summarization to generate an email
with
the pieces that you're going to build up
in in the final template. Exactly.
How do we get more BAML in the training
set? Dude, I'm tired of deleting colons
whenever I generate BAML code. We will
just support colons and that is how we
actually solve that problem. We made a
mistake. Oh, okay.
That is really the real problem there.
Um that was us trying to be clever and
make syntax easier, but it turns out
that was incorrect.
So when we do this, the subject we
already get from our old uh prompting
video. So we we just call this
oops my AirPods died. So I'll be on here
AI that works cracking the prompting
interview.
The next thing that we'll do is we'll
just figure out that we covered.
There we go. Where we dive into where we
dive into
uh this session. So, this email
structure, what this is doing now is
this is actually going to go ahead and
generate this email pretty easily.
Oh, whoops.
From that structure, you can see what
it's actually able to go do. It doesn't
actually struggle that much when I just
wanted to fill in the blanks. When I
wanted to go fill in the blanks to just
make it feel good, it can do this really
easily from the main takeaways in the we
covered section. The question that I
have to ask myself is what Dexter was
talking about last time is how can I get
it to go generate these sections really
really accurately
and that's why we actually built
two prompts here to generate the email.
One is generate the email draft and the
other one is actually go generate the
email. So generating the email draft
comes from a very basic thing where I
give the video summary, I give the
transcript, I give the video title and
then it generates a draft for me. And
the draft consists of these five
sections. It literally just consists of
each of these.
And now I'm able to go ahead and break
down the problem into smaller sections.
And what the difference here is the
model might choose to respond in each of
these sections with a variety of
different options. It might choose to
respond with a
excuse me, it might choose to respond
with phrases. It might choose to respond
with incomplete sentences, things that
don't flow with each other. And that's
totally acceptable. So we don't have to
think that hard about this. All we
really want to happen here is we just
want to get the content mostly correct
out of this problem. Now again, okay, so
you're not using deterministic template.
You're not like generate the bullet
points and then I'm going to like glue
this all together by hand. You're
actually just like, hey, generate it in
a structured way and then I'm going to
hand that to something whose only job is
to like turn it back into a full
coherent email. Exactly. Don't And the
new thing doesn't add new content. It
doesn't do anything. It just makes it
coherent with another template that we
have in mind.
And the difference here is like that's
the difference between like it feeling
like ma mad libs. Like mad libs they're
fun I guess as a joke but no one would
actually send mad lib stuff. It feels
bad to go read that and it doesn't
really read nicely as well because our
content is a little bit more dynamic
than everything else. So this is I think
where people can bridge LMS. I still
want my content to be broken down to
this generic structure.
But what I don't want to happen is I
don't want the email to feel way too
loose in the beginning because if I
don't give it a structure, then I have
to try and prompt my way to getting this
email to feel this way every single
time. But what I can do now is I can
just have a section that does this. And
I can just like put like make this an
array if I want because I think this is
going to be better. Use my Gemini
because Gemini in my opinion is a
superior model for this problem. Um,
and then lastly, we're going to go do
the same thing, which is again, we're
going to have a lot of context in here.
Um, so I'm just going to move this up
and put my instructions at the bottom
because Gemini prefers that. And I can
do this conditionally as well, so I
don't have to think that hard about
this.
So, you're doing two user messages in a
row there, by the way, which is
something I haven't actually seen that
much. Um, can you talk about why you did
that? Yes, I can. One second. You can
Okay. Um, generate email structure.
Sorry. Draft.
Why did I do two user messages? Oh, I
moved this in the wrong place. I moved
the wrong prompt.
Why did I do two e user messages in a
row? Well, I think what the LMS do under
the hood, and this is just like my
assumption of what they do, is they
definitely inject tokens in for you. So,
when we actually go look at the raw curl
request, for example, I have the
transcript and everything here, but I
basically have like two content parts in
here. I like one content part that is
the initial one and a second content
part that's the other one. And the
reason that I don't do this that I do
this is because Gemini
um does something weird with system
messages. I'll show you what it does.
Oops.
Uh, which is for some reason Gemini
likes to put system messages not as a
part of it. Um,
let me make this bigger. Oh, it comes in
a different part of the request.
Exactly.
And you can see how big this context is.
So, it's kind of annoying. Um, oh yes,
Gemini doesn't actually support system
messages in this way. If you try and
pass in a system message to Gemini in
this way, it doesn't actually work. You
can do it this way, but like it just
does it as a different part of the
request. And I can pass into the system
instructions, but empirically what I
have found is the model just doesn't
listen to that. It seems to listen to
the most recent tokens more.
So I just embed it at the very bottom
down here whenever I'm using Gemini. And
what I actually do under the hood is I
actually usually do something like this.
Oh, otherwise you would put a system
message at the top.
Exactly. So, it does give me a little
bit of flexibility over here where it's
like I add it in if it's there,
otherwise I don't. And like in the case
of Gemini, I get I get like a second
user message basically. Um, and that for
me works quite well. But now when I'm
actually going to go run this, what I'll
find is the email comes out kind of
nicely. So it gives me a quick recap
which if you remember the cracking the
prompting interview like this was a
thing. Don't avoid long meaningless
tokens, sequences, URLs, etc. for
diorization and mint indexes. This is a
pretty good summary of what we have.
Utilize inline comments within the
model. Practice RTFP. Read the effing
prompt. Use fshot prompting to define
the output structure, not necessarily
the content. So it has a pattern to
follow and this summary is actually
quite good for what we want. And the
problem is it doesn't have a next
session and that's correct. It cannot
possibly have a next session because we
haven't given it that input.
I just want to call out real quick um
you have a function called generate
email draft and then you have a function
called generate email structure and I
think the names might be flipped. Yes,
that is don't try to change it now.
Um that is almost definitely true and
this is probably because I initially had
email uh structure just draft and it was
doing the whole thing it was doing the
whole email from input to output. Um
this uh is a good point. I'll rename
this before I dude. Yeah, don't change
it now because it's going to break all
the code. But yeah,
uh the next thing that I want to pass
into this is I want to pass in uh uh
event
event details.
And the event details will have the
event name, the date, the time and
location. You need the URL too.
uh uh ID
inviting
and I'll pass in next event
next session. We'll go in there and
we'll just add this into here.
Um and now my test case will go back to
merit gun. add a little test case
and this is kind of the nice thing about
this is the next session will be let's
say the next session will be like
generating uh content AI content
pipeline
AI powered
content pipeline July 15th 2025
cool
um yeah we do have a description on
those as well if you go look at the Luma
client so I would probably add that
cool let's do that.
And again, I could dump this as JSON.
I'm just choosing not to because it's
better to dump it without the quotation
marks and everything else if I can avoid
it. um
on this
at this
um and then the invite link
and I'm just trying to make this easier.
Uh, next session link invite
join.
Oops.
Link.
I'm just trying to make this easier for
the LLM to go read. So, if I go read
this, I keep running this test again.
Oh, man. I got to do that today, too. I
know the
what we should find is again the recap
is still pretty good covers roughly the
uh same content and boom our next
session on July 15th will be about AI
generated content. Here's the link. Now
obviously the link can be elucinated. So
what I would do if I were doing this is
I would just validate the link is
correct. And really what I would do is
like what I would really do is I'd
actually put a placeholder link in
there. Uh, so I do like luma dot uh next
AI
works uh like 12.
A I I do AI that works 12. And the
reason I don't put a pure placeholder
link is because the LM will not
hallucinate. We'll be like, "Oh, that's
a placeholder link. Maybe I'll
substitute something for you." But
putting something like this gets you
something that's like close enough that
it looks real but not wrong enough uh
that it can't get it wrong because these
are not that many tokens. So now it'll
have a lot more reliability that the
model will dump out the invite. And then
what would you just do like a find
replace in the final in the final output
and replace it with the with with the
real link. Literally what I would do.
Cool. And then what I and now what's
nice about this is converting this
structure to like an email format. I
think that's something we all believe an
LLM could do. So now we don't have to
think about this as much. Now we can go
to the Oops. I I don't know why I had
that. Again, you're just you're just
guiding the thought process. Basically,
you're forcing it to think about
different parts of what the email is
going to be. And that makes it really
easy for the next the next LM call to
just generate an email that matches what
we want instead of it having to kind of
do those two steps of okay, let me break
this down into parts and then let me go
turn it into a nice email. Exactly. So,
and and now when we when I submit this,
I'm going to run the previous draft
again. Run email structure just so
people get an idea what it looks like.
And we can actually read this email and
just see what we feel because I think
feel it's this is a feeling based task.
Hello, first name. We should fix the
first name thing. We have to keep tabs
of that. This we from AI from Vib index.
We covered a lot of different topics.
This looks really good. Actually, when I
go look at this, it doesn't have the
GitHub link and it doesn't have the URL
probably because we didn't give it to
it. So, that makes sense. It's not going
to have that, but it does have the Luma
link. Join us for the next session
generate for to generate content for
various use cases. That's pretty good.
If we had a better description, I bet
this would be better. And I think this
email is actually good enough for us to
go send out.
And this it doesn't matter that this is
perfect or not, but this I can just
read. Our Dex can just read and we can
like is this good enough? No, we can
edit this manually because it's just one
sentence we have to go edit now because
the rest of this looks really really
high quality. And why did I know? And
the trick here is we tried GD40, it
didn't work. We tried Claude, it didn't
work. We tried Sonnet. We tried Gemini.
Gemini works with Flash. Great. I'm just
going to use that because it's dirt
cheap and free. Basically, our problem
is solved. And now we have a tone that I
think feels much better than the
original. Can you do you have the drafts
of the email running on your machine,
Dexter? Yeah, I don't think I have this
code though. You don't need this code. I
mean, just running the code that we have
on your screen. If we look just do the
resummarize.
Well, just look at this. This email just
reads that feels like AI generated an
email. Yeah, this sucks. The one that we
were looking if you send me this email
I'm unsubscribing by above. Exactly. And
the one that we see now is much better.
So we've been able to fully autoate the
pipeline get the tone. But the big part
about getting the tone today was really
about getting the data getting the right
data in the right place. And that's all
we focused on. And once we got the right
data then it was picking the right model
that could do the task because we know
that models can get toned probably
correct. We just have to find the right
one that matches our use case. for our
use case that happened to be uh Gemini
and then we broke the problem into two
steps. Generate the generate the
content, generate the actual email and
that seems to work.
All right. I have I have one question
for you before we jump into questions
from the audience. Yeah. Um the world of
AI moves really fast and we're all
constantly learning things. Uh, so if I
can take a slightly off topic for one
second, uh, do you have a fresh AI hot
take? Something that you've seen a lot,
like maybe not even related to this
content, but like what's a strong
opinion that you've had to voice in the
last week that might be valuable to the
audience here. Um, use more AI than you
think and use less AI than you think at
the same time. Um, I think it's been a
really interesting learning for me
personally. Uh, and it really actually
came from talking to kids that are much
younger uh than uh me. Uh, because I've
been coding for a while. I'm kind of set
in my ways and I don't really like to
change how I code. I just code the way I
code. Um, but I've been watching some
younger kids code and it's interesting
what they use AI for. For example, copy
and paste. I will never manually paste
something ever again. I literally will
just ask an alarm to do it or have
cursor tab autocomplete it. It is
really, really freaking good.
I naturally I was I I could think how to
do that for AI but it was my first
instinct and now copy and paste is just
an AI feature. It is not a copy and
paste feature. it is a pure AI feature
for me and like interesting that changed
my behavior and I think there are other
places like for example when we're doing
the folder renaming we could pass in all
the folders into it but if it's trivial
to do the right thing just do the right
thing and just pass in only the folder
names instead of all the files because
you'll just make your own life easier.
So I think that's what I mean by use
more AI than you think. Like use it for
places that you're probably not
imagining using for like copy and paste.
Oh, and stop trying to use AI for dumb
[__] that you could vibe code in five
lines. Exactly. Like the PR thing. Like
why vibe code the perfect readme and a
perfect PR creator when I know I only
need to do two read me files and find a
balance of where that is is actually I
think a really really artful um
position. That's cool. Do you want to
hear mine? Yeah. I feel like I keep
saying this. Uh and there's a lot I This
is inspired. I saw a lot of MCP talk in
the chat. Um, I think if you are
building agents and you are building
code and you're building AI products, I
I don't think MCP was designed or is
very good as like a replacement for
traditional SDKs. We've said this in our
MCP episode as well is like SDK is MCP
is not a building block for building
production AI agents as products. MCP is
an incredibly powerful toolkit that is
changing the world because it allows
non-technical or like much less
technical people to add functionality to
existing AI user experiences.
And like your app, your production
agent, the thing you're shipping,
something you want people to use should
absolutely support and implement MCP,
but not in the sense of like, oh, I'm
going to use a bunch of MCP servers and
like put them under the hood inside my
app that no one knows about, but you
should implement an MCP client so that
anybody using your app can add new
functionality whenever they want. Yeah,
exactly. And that functionality will be
less reliable than the native
functionality you have built in.
But it will be more it will allow them
to extend the capabilities and that's
kind of cool is
um all right we got a lot of stuff going
on in the chat um specific questions
people want to do uh if anyone wants to
share their their hot take of the week
um happy to hear that as
Um,
so I guess the long the long thread was
I'm trying to decide if this will be
useful for my code generation and review
rag. Is this a good way to orchestrate
the agentic workflow or not so much? And
then I think there's
what? Show me your t-shirt.
Oh, we got to get people the human layer
t-shirt.
Oh, uh, merch layer.dev. And if you ping
me privately on Twitter or LinkedIn,
I'll send you a promo code for a
discount.
Um, let's talk about where do you see AI
risk surface expanding? Um, I think the
biggest area of AI risk surface is
actually data leakage and data security.
Um, that's super underrated, especially
as more people send more stuff to AI
pipelines. When an AI pipeline randomly
has a tool injected into it, like SQL
injections for example,
you're going to have a like we figured
out how to deal with SQL injection. We
just escape them. There's no way to
escape inputs to your prompts. So like
that's going to be a huge huge area uh
that people have to deal with somehow.
Um and I'm not sure exactly how we'll do
that universally.
What about you, Dex? What do you think?
spending
uh
we waste time on stupid [__] that
doesn't work.
I think the like I don't know there was
this joke of like oh computers will
allow us to work 100% faster. They're
going to double our productivity. Then
it's like oh computers generate 100%
more work. So it's like it's kind of a
wash.
I don't know. There's going to be some
version of that with AI.
Yeah. Exactly. What's the next one?
What's your take on cloud code hooks?
Yes.
Uh I don't know what that is. I have to
go look at that.
Yeah. It's like cursor. It's like
extensions that you can write personally
that basically will like give Claude
code special commands that you can have.
So like for example, you can have like
rename file that just has instruction on
what you do or you can make like an
agent that does research where you tell
cloud code spin up 15 agents. Yeah.
Wait, we've been using this for weeks.
This is just commands. This has been
around forever. Yeah.
Yeah, that's my point. So we have been
having commands all the time, but these
are hooks. Is that I'm not getting the
difference like how it is different.
I will uh I will look into this. We did
say that we would do an episode on vibe
coding, which would be a little off
topic for what we generally talk about,
but I think could be a lot of fun. So,
maybe we'll talk about this one as well.
Yeah. Okay. So, pre-tool use, post tool
use, notification.
I think, yeah, this is super
interesting. They're experimenting with
a way to let other people build on top
of Cloud Code because it helps build an
ecosystem for them. Um, and like
maybe that happens to be true where like
people want to use a clawed agent loop
to go do something. Um, and it becomes a
slightly more general purpose agent, but
I think that's
that's kind of what that is for them.
Um, whether it's good or not really
depends on like the quality of the hooks
that people build out and like what
unique ideas people come up with. It's
like the app store and Apple. Like the
app store and Apple could have been a
total of flop, but it turned out to be
really good because Angry Birds is
really really fun.
Um again no reason I'm just using it to
you know ring a bell once one of my like
agent kind of session that is done or
waiting for permission. So it just like
a bell so it was not possible before.
Exactly. And now you can go do that and
like that's what I mean there's small
things like that where it's like if they
don't get the UX just right allows other
people to go make things slightly
incrementally better.
I think that's interesting.
Um, is there any world where we can use
DSPI with BAML in the future? Uh, I
think they're right about prompts being
the wrong abstraction since they
basically just automate eval driven
iteration on prompts, but I don't like
how they do structured output. Um,
I think there's a really underst thing
about how people think about prompts and
context in general. Uh, and I think this
goes back to what Dex often says about
context engineering. The problem that I
see generally with the way that people
are doing automatic eval driven
developments on prompts is they they
iterate on the whole prompt at the same
time and that is not very useful like
I'll give you an example really fast
just to make it a little bit more
concrete and this is kind of and like I
I like bam will be extensible so like
once we provide the a then you can do
whatever you want within Python we just
haven't built that yet so like in some
sense yes but fundamentally like let's
just take a look at this so I have a
prompt that generates this email
structure. We talked about this today.
If the thing that is not good is the
quick recap, there's many ways that I
could have solved this. Before quick
recap used to be a string and it was
just not as good. By making it a string
array, I was able to get better recaps
coming out of it.
Whether you call that optimizing the
prompt or optimizing something else, I
don't know. I don't think Well, that's
part of the signature. Like if you're
using DSP, you'd literally have to
physically change the signature.
Exactly. And that's why I think like the
actual prompting part isn't actually
constrained to what it is. And we might
even find that the right way to do this
is like uh recap might be like a recap
might look like this. It might actually
be like title string uh description
string. And like what I really want to
do here is like this.
And whether and maybe I want to add a
description here at most three four to
10 words. And now it's getting to be
really sophisticated at a way that like
you typically don't want to navigate
English itself.
And that's I think the main problem that
I see with most prompt optimization
tools is that they try and navigate the
middle chunk of the prompt, but they
overlook the fact that the prompt itself
is comprised of a giant a that is very
very complex. And as our programs become
more complex, we'll become harder and
harder to just like edit in the pure
prompting side.
I will say like just to play devil's
advocate like for the DSPI side like
rather than prompting like I think and
like maybe maybe I don't fully
understand this but like my my
understanding would be like rather than
telling the LM to use X number of words
you would basically set up a metric and
then you would count the words that came
out and then you would like penalize it
for too many words or not enough words
and then over time the model the prompt
engineering framework would probably
learn to say okay the string that gets
the right number of words is to say
these like use four to 10 words, but you
wouldn't have to write that. You would
write the hey, here's the rules, here's
the metric. Yeah, that's that's exactly
right. Like you kind of you I mean you
give it a signature and then you express
kind of an evaluation function that you
know can be any combination of like
string based you know any properties of
the generated thing if it's structured.
Um, it can also use LLM as a judge if
you want and then it will kind of
iteratively run that against, you know,
an LLM with your evaluation function and
it'll figure out like which, you know,
it'll try update like having the LLM
write things to update parts of the
prompts that are not performing well and
then see how they behave. It's almost
like like conceptually like a little bit
like a genetic algorithm. It'll try
different things to improve the parts
that the evals um determine are
performing badly and it'll pick whatever
helps the most and and kind of add that
to the prompt iteratively. So yeah, you
just express like what good looks like
in that evaluation however you want to
and then it will
figure out okay what actually works. The
only tricky part about that is that part
of doing the application on what you
actually want to go change in the prompt
is really really varied.
So there are some things that you could
do. For example, like you could this
like the sentence of at most 410 words.
Let's assume that a human didn't write
that but a model did. You can write that
in many different places. You can write
that here. You can write that uh here.
You can write that you can write that as
a description field here. Oops.
Yeah. And so that's kind of what it's
figuring out for you is like not just
what should be added to it, but where
should it be added to it to get really
good results. Yeah, exactly. So that
will become possible once we expose the
a but we really need to just expose the
a in an iterative way and then like the
model can decide how to go inject it
because what you're really doing here is
you're modifying the code at runtime
and that part is the part that needs to
be uh analyzed and retroactively like
you need to be able to walk the syntax
that we have and like clearly we can
walk the syntax but we just don't expose
an SDK to go do that yet but we will
that we've tried iteration iteration
loops like this before and it seems to
work pretty Especially if we're
generating new schemas, that's where we
find that the model is really really
good. Like for example, if the recap is
bad, it will actually just create a
schema. Uh or it'll change it like a
string array or something else inside.
And that seems to work quite well.
Cool. Um last question I think we can
call it. Yeah, go ahead. Um I like the
what's the coolest thing you've seen
built with BAML?
Clearly this guy just came here to get a
BAML pitch and I'm happy to oblige.
Um what's the oh sorry there's like
seven or eight different question let me
just go down really fast I the first one
I saw was what's the versioning just use
git or like have two variables that you
pass in and forth like if you have two
variables you can just use that the
coolest thing that I have seen built are
honestly not about the extent of the
pipeline it's really about how good they
are so for me things are personally
really really cool when they actually
work like 99.9% of the time like this
email content pipeline that we built
wasn't that cool last week to me because
it didn't actually produce a good email.
The email that we just saw today was
pretty good. That becomes cool. What
I've seen are pipelines that process
like bank statements with like 100 pages
plus. Those are really exciting when
they don't have errors. Um pipelines
processing tax forms, those are really
exciting because again, very sensitive
data and it just works. Uh hospital
records. Uh I think those are I think
the most interesting problems to me
personally. But I think things that
other people probably find really cool
are probably along the lines of um like
there's this agentic framework that
someone built that not agentic framework
an AI assistant that someone built that
you can just talk to in your car and
just does like seven or eight different
things and they did that by adding a
bunch of MCP tools. I think if you look
in our share your share your creations
channel will have it in there that I
thought was really really really wild.
Um what about you Dex? I know you've
built some really cool things.
Yeah. Uh I
I think it's less about like what you
can do specifically with BAML and more
like it's all about the application,
right? Like BAML just helps you get the
performance pretty good without having
to think about tuning and tool calls and
all that kind of stuff. Um and it
provides a good development experience
for testing and evaluating this stuff.
So, I mean, I've built two things with
Pamel that I really like, which is like
a Slackbot that manages all of our
GitHub deployments and a email assistant
that like you can just forward emails to
it and it like looks up a list of tools
with BAML and responds and has like just
like has become it went from being just
like trash dumping JSON into the context
window to something that's really really
clean and really high reliability and
works really fast and doesn't use too
many tokens. So, it was fun iterating in
that direction with it. Yeah. I think
the things that I found really cool in
general, the ones that you built is just
like the UX pattern of like being able
to interrupt the workflow when it's
running with like a feedback loop. That
was not a thought process that really
came across my mind until we worked
together for the first time, which is
idea that like I want human guided
agents where I can like that's why
cursor is so freaking good. like cursor
is really good or any of these systems
like cloud code is really good because
while the agent's working I can chat
with it and it can interrupt change the
workload into the direction that I want
that UX is really important to build
this is Karpathy talked about this in
his YC talk he was like like good AI
tools have an autonomy slider there's
like zero autonomy where I'm editing the
code there's a little bit of autonomy
where it's like tab complete but it just
shows like suggestions and I accept them
and then there's like full agent mode
and then there's like other there's ask
mode, there's like things in the middle.
And so like being able to build AI
experiences that have that again
autonomy slider, different levels of
autonomy for different modes of work and
like polish versus broadstrokes versus
planning versus high level um I think is
really important. And like full agent
mode is interesting, but full agent mode
without being able to stop it and
correct course correct along the way is
really really really bad.
And like that's why that UX is critical.
Um, but with that, I think that's
today's episode. Uh, hopefully you guys
saw the content. We'll push all the
prompts out, so you'll have access to
it. Uh, and today's email should come
back in a fully AI generated way. So,
um, it's going to be fun to go see and
you'll see the ghetto read me launch
soon as well. And if this week goes
well, then we'll start uploading pretty
um, if if things if this week goes well,
then we might start increasing the
upload rate to Wednesday because we got
an automated pipeline. Uh, remember when
you wanted to hire an intern to do this
work? Yeah. It turns out eight hours uh
16 hours of our time does the job, too.
Oh, god. Dude, this is super fun. Thanks
everybody for the questions. Catch you
all next week. Bye-bye.